ils ont moins fait l'actualité ces
derniers temps sans doute parce qu'à la
différence des étudiants eux ont pu
continuer à aller en classe ce sont les
collégiens elle travaille dur en vue du
brevet dans cinq mois maintenant comment
gérer son stress le jour de l'examen
comment mieux s'exprimer à l'oral des
compétences qui ne s'apprennent pas dans
les livres mais que le théâtre
d'improvisation peut aider à acquérir
exemple au collège saint-etienne de
chambray-lès-tours qui organisait cette
semaine plusieurs ateliers flanc clavel
apprendre à capter le regard de l'autre
a parlé d'une voix assurée avec le
sourire en plus et sans livre ses élèves
de collège sont bien en cours
un cours de théâtre d'improvisation au
coeur de la pratique des jeux de rôles
et de rapidité
l'objectif c'est déjà qu'ils soient plus
à l'aise qu'ils soient conscients de ce
qu'ils font voilà et d'avoir vraiment
cette détente d'aller chercher cette
détente et ce plaisir de faire voilà et
moi j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus parce
que quand on a le plaisir de faire on a
on a déjà la moitié du chemin qui est
fait la moitié du chemin vers l'oral du
brevet car cet atelier un but
pédagogique les élèves de 3e devront
faire une présentation de textes suivis
d'un entretien avec le jury
une épreuve d'expression qui compte
autant que les matous le français dans
l'obtention du diplôme et à cinq mois de
l'épreuve
la pression monte ouais je sais qu'un
geste rare de ne pas connaître ça mon
texte
oui j'aurais quelques astuces pour
m'aider chance au niveau de la
respiration
on évolue aussi par rapport
à la société et voilà il ya beaucoup de
la prise de parole prend une place très
importante et effectivement quelqu'un
qui a des compétences à l'oral par
rapport à deux candidats pour un pour un
futur métier
eh bien on prendra peut-être
effectivement la personne qui est
beaucoup plus à l'aise et n'a toi mais
je vous en prie ok super après trois
heures d'atelier le résultat final est
concluant ça m'a permis d' un peu
prendre confiance en moi et d'avoir une
voix beaucoup plus nette du coup c'est
intéressant parce qu'on a pu travailler
sur la voie la posture est sûr aussi la
peur des autres par la peur du regard
des autres
ça c'est un problème pourtant oui je
pense que c'est ce qui est le plus dur à
gérer ce à partir de ça que je pense que
vient le stress avec le regard des
autres les trois classes de troisième du
collège ont pu profiter du programme et
des bases d'une meilleure aisance à
l'oral qui leur seront profitables tout
au long de leur vie